- That was one of the
best days of my life.
Honestly, like signing day,
just knew that all the
hard work that I had put
into this dream final paid off.
I'm Noble. I'm a freshman
at Brown University.
I play receiver on the football team.
It became apparent to me that
when I got to high school
that if I wanted to achieve the goals
of going Division One football
and going to school in the Ivy League,
that I needed to improve on my SAT scores.
A lot of people like my
peers have test anxiety.
First time I took it, I got a 1210.
I knew I needed to
improve if I wanted to get
to a level of school that I'd envisioned.
So, I dug into Khan Academy a lot.
I took advantage of the option
to upload your SAT scores
to Khan Academy, and it
would give you feedback
on things you needed to work on.
I definitely took a lot of
stress off of my shoulders
and like having the confidence
that I could truly go
into this test and perform
to the standards that I
wanted. By using Khan Academy
I was able to improve my
SAT score by 210 points.
I was able to get a 1420,
and that was a score that
got me accepted in the Brown.
Definitely would say it's life changing.
I set my life on trajectory
that wouldn't have been available
if I didn't have access to Khan Academy.
Whether you're upper class or lower class,
or anywhere you fall in between those,
and it's free and available for everyone.
And that's, I can't stress that enough.
I wanna leave a message
that anything is possible.
I definitely think the best
beginning spot would be
through Khan Academy.